at first this problem seems impossible
you need to compare 2 to the power 350
and 5 to the power of 150 without a
calculator
the method to solve these problems is to
factor the exponents 350 is equal to 7
times 50 and 150 is equal to 3 times 50.
substitute those in
now we're going to use an exponent rule
we have the number x to the m raised to
the power of n is equal to x to the
power of MN you want to make sure that X
is a real number M and N are integers
and x and MN cannot both be zero once
we've done that we go ahead and use this
rule so we rewrite each of these
exponents now we're comparing 2 to the 7
and 5 to the 3. 2 to the 7 is 128 5 to
the 3 is 125. so we're comparing 128 to
the 50 versus 125 to the 50 and of
course the first number is larger
therefore 2 to the power of 350 is
greater